next time that you're at a party or any
sort of gathering look at the angle of
the feet of women talking to women and
of men talking to men women will talk to
women 180° they'll be face to face
whereas men the average is 120° once you
see that you can't not see it and it's a
rule that works across so many different
things the men's sheds initiative in
Australia did you see that it was an
initiative by the Australian government
I think uh to try and improve men's
mental health they realized they're
getting men to sit down in a room and
talk like this about their problem
didn't work so what they did is they
built sheds that men came to and then
the men would bring like I've got this
knacked lawn mower and everyone needs to
help fix it so how are men talking
they're talking whilst their front brain
is focused on this thing that's in front
and they are shoulder Tosh shoulder not
face to face they're literally in a
circle and everyone's like right you
you've got the good drill and he's got
the good spanner and I've got the hammer
or whatever and let's fix this thing and
dude me and the misses we're not getting
on well and before you know it it's a
therapy session mediated by this [__]
lawnmower